hello everyone we are taking a short
break from the Capablanca saga to check
up on Leela hs0 and season 14 of the
2019 TCC the top chess engine
competition now for those of you who
don't know what Leela chess is zero is
it's a similar entity to alpha zero only
the developers of Lula chassis or do not
have well the resources the deep mind
has really quick in the development of
Leela so they are using basically
computers from the entire planet whoever
wishes can give Leela access to her to
your computer and then Leela can also
use your resources to better herself and
she's already quite stronger rated
somewhere I think a little bit below
3500 and we're going to talk about the
results of the championship after we
check up on this game but it's a really
impressive game and alpha 0 is a bit
busy at the moment playing Starcraft and
such but they call him alpha star now if
you've seen he really you know destroyed
some elite players in StarCraft those
who follow Starcraft or sure I'm sure
have seen that but if you haven't you
know just google it was very impressive
I was watching it live but getting back
to this game
Leela has the white opened the white
pieces and she opens with d4 and the
thing with the TCC they're using opening
books so the first few moves are always
well they have to use them
so with d4 d5 c4 e6 with Knight to f3 c
6 so this love defense we have Knight to
c3 and now D characters on c4 we have a
4 this is the Noteboom variation and now
Bishop to b4 we have e3 b5 now Bishop to
d2 unpinning now and here we have a 5
and this is a pretty standard line it
has been used plenty you know a lot of
times in talk to your tournaments as
well as in some weaker ones ache after
some b5 first book a person seats
we capture some c3 and now seek actors
on b5 and now as you can see Black has
this very nice
pawn chain on the Queen side that is
ready to push a button the other side on
the other hand our black is lacking in
development as you can see black really
hasn't developed any piece other than
the the dark square bishop that was
traded so b3 attacking the very strong
pawn chain and Bishop the b7 we have
butchered back to be 2 up until this
point it was all in the book I believe
as they didn't say and I don't have
access to every line of the opening but
I believe Bishop to b2 was the first
move out of book by Leo but it's not the
first time the move was played a bar
okay Knight to f6
Houdini keeps developing we have B
captures on c4 and now before now
creating two passed pawns on the Queen
side Bishop to d3 preparing the castle
Houdini castles viola castles and now
comes Knight B to d7 continuing
development we have nice back to d2 and
now Queen to c7 so as you can see Black
has two very strong passed pawns on the
Queen side and also Black has a lot of
pressure here against the White King if
some made threats are about to happen
white white could get in some trouble
but it's all worked out
we're Bishop to c2 and now comes h6
first preparing to keep the black King a
bit safer and the disposition has been
reached a few times in human chess and
the there is one game where efore was
played but here we have rook to e1 and
it is of as of this moment this 17 that
we have a completely new game and the
position that was never reached so rook
F to e 8 any Queen to c6 immediate
threats you can just play e4 and it's
not a problem d5 is coming black it
doesn't really have a way to threaten
the white king just yet
so after rook e1 we have rook F to e8
developing the rook and now comes h3
taking away the g4 square a-square from
the black knight and now comes a 5 now
d5 white would rather grab more space in
the center than exchange in the center
and also now yes black does have to
connect the past points on the queenside
but White has two connected passports in
the center and here we have night the b6
we have E for strengthening the center
and now what's the idea here why why
does white allow black to capture and
see for this is the well first cool
moment we have in the game if Knight
captures then Knight captures and Queen
captures and now well
Bishop today for you attack the rook but
also free the C file for the roof to
attack the Queen and now you have to
give up this exchange if you play
something like rook to e7 then you get
d6 the rock is under attack and if you
play something like rook to e6 then
Bishop to b3 within the exchange once
again once the Queen moves so you would
have to part with the rook
so after efore we first have look at the
c8 rook a to see it seems like a more
natural move as this rook was already
developed but you don't want to diss
ricany eight stay here so so the bishop
can attack at VI da Foursquare so we
have looked at the c8 and now comes Luke
the c1 night F the d7 preparing to put
f5 in some variations but also perhaps
getting the knight to c5 and here or you
can see that everything is happening
will white be faster in pushing in the
center or will Houdini be faster in
pushing on the on the Queen side and
here a little takes the opportunity to
do something awesome here Lila makes a
rock lift we have rook to e3
now Lila will transfer the rope to g3
and start a powerful attack against the
black King we have a for Houdini awaits
no time Houdini wants to play a3 and
start pushing those passed pawns as soon
as possible we have looked to g3 and now
what happens here if black proceeds with
a three well then Queen to g4 will start
an attack against the black king and
this a3 move will be pretty much waste
of time you will have to weaken your
position with g6 and then the bishop
will just move and nothing happens
really
so after rook g3 we have g6 first
defending against the
screen to g4 move that wasn't even
played but now Lela takes this
opportunity and plays Queen to h5 as the
pawn is pinned so this is a different
way to bring the Queen into the game
again if you go a three here then you
allow some ideas like rook captures on
g6 with Czech captures captures you will
lose the H bone as well for example King
f8 and I can capture here and it's hard
to say the rook sacrifice might not be
entirely justified but you will at least
have a draw so Houdini doesn't allow
this and it's not that hard to believe
that this rook can also make a nice root
lift and to finish the job so first King
to h7 Houdini defends the g6 pawn
doesn't allow the rook sacrifice and now
comes Queen back to f3
now the f7 point has been weakened and
Leela attacks it and again you can't
defend it with something like Knights to
c5 so the Queen attacks it because of
Queen to f6 again a very strong move and
now it's hard hard to defend the Bishop
captures and e5 is a huge threat which
would come with an attack on the Queen
and also the threat of checkmate
so black would have to defend the pawn
but then comes d6 the Queen is under
attack and after the Queen moves now you
will be able to capture here and well
the threat of checkmate is here you will
have to do something most likely give up
give up the exchange here and the white
will again be better so after Queen to
f3 we have f6 now the knight controls
the f6 pawn so there's no danger here
and we have h 4 now Lilla wishes to
create more weaknesses we have Queen to
b6 and now comes h5 we have g5 of course
Houdini does not want to open lines and
Queen to f5 with check will came to h8
and now comes f4 this is the the
beautiful attacking move because you can
see that the King is perfectly aligned
with the dark square bishop on this b2h
a diagonal and wood f4 you will either
play G captures and then why it gets a
semi-open file for the rope rook g6 will
be deadly or if you capture which at
this point it's not much better then
rook captures on g5 and after H captures
then comes a five and the white is
blasting through you'd have an attack
against the Queen and also the Bushman
Queen battery threatened the checkmate
on h7 so you would have to defend Queen
e7 but then comes he captures on f6 and
it's just all over Queen f7 then comes
Queen captures on g5 and there are
simply too many threats 9 f8 brush-up g6
you can capture by pawn captures and you
can see that now the points will finish
the job f7 is coming Queen g7 and Queen
H sex will be checkmate so a very
interesting move f4 and we have a three
hood who didn't ignores the pawn and
attacks the bishop bishop 281 and now
comes Queen to e7 and here who didn't
didn't really give Leela all that much
advantage only little advantage in stock
fish that was watching the game stock
Fischer said it's not all that
impressive but then after seeing a few
more moves by Leela even stock fish
agreed that Leela had the advantage here
we have F captures on e5 even though the
other engines were suggesting rook to f1
but okay
he captures F captures on e5 Leela would
definitely want to open up this diagonal
from the bishop to the king we have
Knight captures on e5 and now Bishop to
b3 solidifying on this c4 pawn and also
these two bishops now are a constant
threat for the rest of the game against
the black king for if the position opens
up then the bishop pair will be just a
monstrosity but okay we have Knight B to
d7 strengthening the f6 and the e5
square and now comes Knight to f3 and
now you could you could trade here
Knight captures but then you have
problems rook captures there's a triple
attack against the f6 pawn here rope to
FA the defense but then comes Queen to
g6 and again a white is just breaking
through Queen g7 defends the h6 pawn but
then c5 comes and white is just so much
better here so after Knight of three we
have Queen to h7 Houdini offers a trade
of Queens but Queen back to h3 just
keeping the tension now this knight
cannot move well kid can move with
but it also has to keep an eye on this
night as the Queen is a bit preoccupied
the way to the Kings side we have looked
to a fate by Houdini and now comes
Knight captures on e5 we have Knight
captures on e5 and now not immediately
starting to push our passports but c5
because you would have Bishop to c8 here
attacking the Queen and the Queen
doesn't really have a good square to go
to you you'd have to move the Queen and
then the e4 pawn falls so you do have to
defend against these two threats the
Queen is attacking your e4 pawn and also
Bishop to see it could be quite a
nuisance so look the e3 defending the
point and making some room for the Queen
we have Bishop the a6 now Queen to g3 by
Leela and now rook 8 e8 and here it's a
very interesting yes you do have a lot
of options here you could just start
pushing your passed pawns and well it
could do this this Leela finds a
different approach and it's quite quite
a beautiful move
Leela plays a push up to d4 the threat
is Bishop to c5 attacking the rook on f8
and also the pawn on b4 so how do you
prevent this it's not all that easy if
you try something like Knights to d7 to
defend this square here you get Queen to
d6 you allow the Queen into the game and
then with the Queen here it's just the
position place itself another thing you
could try after Bishop to d4 is look to
f7 with ideas of okay if the bishop
attacks I could defend with this but
then just c5 and the rook is really
awkwardly placed here then the placement
of the rook will just help white pull
the passed pawns and yet another thing
you could do is Queen to b7 just trying
to prevent everything with the Queen but
against e5 and the white will just use
the awkward position of the black Queen
to advance his pawns or leeloo spawns so
after Bishop to d4 we have the Queen to
g7 alia decides to give up the exchange
for some counter play with Bishop to c5
and now comes look to be a the other
rogue defends the b-pawn which is the
defender of the past form that's already
on a3 and Houdini decides that this is
much more important than the
can f8 first Bishop to d6 Lila says ok I
will grab the exchange but only only
when I have to
so here Houdini forces it we have look F
to d8 attacking the bishop and only now
does Lila capture the exchange Bishop
captures rook captures and now rook et1
connecting the ropes back again there
will be increased control of the a1
square and also it frees the e3 square
for whites Queen so the White Queen can
now well not by this means but can
perhaps infiltrate blacks position we
have Queen to d7 and now comes look II
to d1 now both pawns are protected here
and it's a well apparent on a nice
principle in chess you don't want to put
your roots behind your passed pawns with
King to g7 by Houdini and now finally
Leela starts pushing the passport we
have c5 Bishop to b5 and now comes Queen
to III as the e3 square was so
conveniently freed for Leela's Queen
with Knight g4 attacking the Queen now
comes Queen to h3 not allowing this
Knights to move you can't repeat moves
here because here Queen captures just
wins on the spot if you just try to
repeat moves Knight captures c6 is
coming after the knight moves you can
all push c7 and after Luke c8 d 6 is
coming and there's just no stopping this
if a Bishop d7 then rook d4 and now all
of all of lacks pieces are tied
controlling the pawns here and black
will just start taking up the Queen side
pawns as or you could just say the rook
will gobble them up so after Queen to h3
we have looked to a eight preparing to
push the past a pawn but now rook to e1
look back to f8 a black decides to wait
and see what Leela will do and now comes
Bishop to d1 threatening to capture the
night here we have Knight back to e5 and
now Leah finally trades Queens as this
was forced
Queen captures with Bishop captures and
now not immediately pushing the pawn
because if you push then you get an ID 3
it will fork the ropes and also the
rooks are under
and the bishop is between them and they
are not connected so after Bishop
captures d7 first rookie three not
allowing the Knights to go here
look the c8 and only now c6 attacking
the bishop bishop to e8 pressuring the
h5 pawn but now rook the b1 Knights the
c-4 attacking the rook rook to d3 and
now nice to be to attacking the rook and
the bishop we have rook to b3 and now
comes a two and this was Leah's plan now
Leola decides to give back the exchange
we have rook three capture Sun B to a
capture some b1 promoting to a queen or
to any other piece it doesn't really
matter here as a joke Houdini Houdini
actually brought a bishop into the game
rook captures on b1 and now comes b3 b3
with the idea okay if if Bishop captures
then the bishop no longer guards the h5
pawn this bishop can just capture it or
if rope captures perhaps Houdini's plan
was to give up a piece for for two
points here and try to hold this to a
draw but Leela doesn't allow it Leela
doesn't capture it but first Bishop to
g4 and it's a really an impressive move
now there's not all that much you can do
here for example if you move the rook
rook the rook to c7 then rook captures
and b3 is coming and now if you try to
bring your King back into the game room
b7 captures captures and you cannot stop
promotion on a dark square
so after this Bishop to g4 move Houdini
tried rook captures on c6 it's a
desperate move but Houdini decided to
try something we have D captures on c6
Bishop captures on c6 and now rook
captures on b3 and now as you can see
Leo is up a whole rook Houdini played a
few more moves King f7 Bishop to f5 King
to e7 and here after King to f2 who
didn't play Bishop 38 and it was in this
position that Houdini resigned the game
or as it is with engines I believe I
simply took him too long to decide on
playing brush up to 8 so there's like an
algorithm that decides that Houdini
actually resigned but yeah this was the
last game they played
match and all of the games were drawn
and then this was the final game they
played before going into the tiebreaks
and Leela was able to win it with the
white pieces so very impressive and I
did prepare this but it's it's quite
large so well I'll just have to move it
for you to check up how Leela played
this entire Championship there you can
see firstly latch s0 against engine
tucano 8 to 0 then Leela played against
Sipos or she posed beat him 6 to 2 then
Leela advanced against on socks and
defeated him five and a half to two and
a half and then here we have the
semi-finals stockfish vs. Houdini
Houdini was able to beat stockfish 6 to
5 against 5 to 5 and Leela was able to
beat Komodo 10 to 8 and there we have
the finals this is a the last game from
the finals Leela chess 0 vs. Houdini
four and a half against five and a half
so beating him by a one-point margin and
third and fourth place was decided
between stockfish and Komodo and it's
like that in every season it's always
Houdini astonishing Komodo and then and
now this is the first time that Leela
jezero was able to win this championship
but this is only the finals now Leela
goes into the super finals where she
where she faces a stronger version of
stockfish I will also put a link to that
in the description below it will be the
first thing you will see sorry the
second thing you will see the first
thing you will see will be a link to the
little hs0 blog where you can follow up
on all of the Leo hs0 news but the
second link in the description will be a
link to the live this match is going on
now a Leela will play a hundred games
against this stronger version of
stockfish and I believe so far all of
the games have been drawn but you know
you're welcome to check it out and and
follow this match live and the winner of
the super finals will be proclaimed that
the the season 14 TCC champion it would
be really cool if Leela could win this
and then perhaps you know perhaps it
could be used to promote such a match
like maybe a little a chess 0 versus
alpha 0 if deepmind would be interested
in such a magic but it would be
really I think it would be I don't know
it would the entire world would be
watching that as I think that would be
the first time where we would have two
different self learning neural net
artificial intelligences facing each
other which I believe now with even a
different architecture buddy on now who
knows first allele has to defeat this
superior superior version of stock fish
and then maybe sometimes in the future
we'll have a match Leela 0 vs alpha zero
I think that I'd be pretty psyched for
that but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and that well and that
Leela will have a successful match again
stock fish and yeah hopefully hopefully
we will see a Leela alpha match in the
future I don't know I would just be very
happy for that and yeah obviously now
there's no point in continuing this game
white is up a whole rook soon I would
like to thank last role of force Tyler
Davis d3 Patrick Paul Staples and
Hawking dr. liedel for a contribution to
my channel think a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
I'm most likely continuing the
capablanca saga but also as always
checking up on your suggestions so thank
you all and I will see you soon